our subject for today
relationships have rules
relationships have rules let not your
heart be troubled you believe in God
believe also in me in my father's house
are many mansions if it were not so I
would have told you I go to prepare a
place for you and if I go to prepare and
prepare a place for you I will come
again and receive you unto myself that
where I am there you may be also and
whether I go ye know and the way ye know
Thomas sayith unto him Lord we know not
with thou goest and how can we know the
way Jesus said unto him I am the way the
truth and the life no man cometh unto
the father but by me
if he had known me you should have known
my father also and from henceforth you
know him and have seen him Philip saith
unto him Lord show us the father and it
sufficeth us Jesus said unto him have I
been so long time with you and yet hast
thou not known me Phillip he that have
seen me have seen the father and how
sayest thou then show us the father
believest thou not that I am in the
father and the father in me the words
that I speak unto you I speak not of
myself but the father that dwelleth in
me he doeth The Works believe me or else
believe me for the very work sake verily
verily I say unto you he that believeth
on me the works that I do shall he do
also and Greater Works than thee shall
he do because I go unto my father and
whatsoever he shall ask in my name that
will I do that the father may be
glorified in the son if he shall ask
anything in my name I will do it if you
love me keep my
Commandments I thank God again and
always will for the privilege of
speaking for him it is a high high
privilege and I ask him to grant me his
Spirit as the Bible says we have this
treasure in earn vessels
and I am an earn vessel a vessel of clay
a vessel of dirt therefore the glory
must be to God because there is no glory
in dirt of itself and so I'm grateful to
Pastor Javan for the invitation and for
the honor and the pleasure of
fellowshipping with his church family I
enjoy all the music may the Lord bless
you those of you who sign those of you
who read the scripture may God always
work in your lives to draw you closer
closer to him and may God be so close to
you that those who see you will somehow
get a glimpse of Jesus Christ I welcome
the little boys and the little girls who
are watching I'm always delighted when
children listen to the word of God God
is pleased my little brother God is
pleased my little sister when we give
our children give their lives to him and
God can use you as powerfully as he can
use an adult you can obey God because
God will provide the power for you to
obey him to those of you watching who
are not 7eventh the Adventist thank you
very much for joining us and I ask the
god of Heaven and Earth to bless your
lives to touch you to protect you to
provide for you sustain you to doubly
bless your children and to save you in
his kingdom when he comes and he is
coming
thanks again for joining with
us I understood one on one occasion that
the vice Chancellor of um Spicer was
present may the Lord bless him
leadership is not easy may God grant him
wisdom so that that school may be a
lighthouse of God's glory all the church
leaders who are watching may the Lord
give you the wisdom he gave to Solomon
that you may guide his people as
Faithfully as Moses led the Israelites
all our subject for today
relationships have rules
relationships have
rules before I get into the message I
call upon you as always preserve
reverence where you are the Bible says
in Malachi 3:6 I am the Lord I change
not God is as holy on Monday as he is on
Sabbath the Sabbath is Holy Monday is
not but the Sabbath does not make God
Holier on that day than he is on Tuesday
I say that to say this God is Holy
whether we worship him in the church or
on Zoom keep in mind the absolute
Holiness of God and preserve reverence
where you are imagine you're sitting in
a courtroom in the presence of a judge
an Earthly judge you will be quiet you
will not use your phone you will not
chat you will not whatever you won't do
these things in the presence of an
Earthly judge we are in the presence of
the judge of all the Earth let's Grant
to him the reverence that he deserves
favor number two while I'm speaking pray
for me and say Lord put your words in
that man's mouth when God sent Moses to
speak to Pharaoh Moses did not want to
go he said he was slow of speech God
made a promise to him in Exodus 4:2
which says this now therefore go and I
will be with thy mouth and teach thee
what Thou shalt say I want God to do
that for me 2 Samuel
23:2 the spirit of the Lord spake by me
and his word was in my tongue I want God
to do that for me and finally Jeremiah 1
ver9 then the Lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth and the Lord said
unto me behold I have put my words in
thy mouth so ask God seriously to put
his words in my mouth and favor number
three think as you listen Isaiah 1118
come now let us reason together said the
Lord the god of the universe will take
time to reason with you as an individual
a remarkable consideration that God is
willing to reason he came down into the
Garden of Eden to reason with Adam he
spoke to Cain to reason with him God is
willing to listen listen to us to reason
with us he calls upon us let's reason
together let us
pray Father in Heaven thank you for
this moment of
worship thank you for your
love thank you for
life thank you for the constant
convictions of the holy
spirit thank you for the protection of
your
angels thank you for the friendship and
fellowship of fellow
Believers thank you for the knowledge of
Jesus thank you de God that wherever we
are we still enjoy some degree of
freedom of religion and
worship as we bow in your presence
father if we have sinned against you
forgive us dear God Micah 7:18 tells us
who is a god like unto thee that pardon
iniquity and passees by the
transgression of the remnant of his
Heritage father there's no one forgives
the way you do if we have sinned forgive
us and cast our sins into the depths of
the sea I humble myself before you and I
ask you de God to take absolute control
of my mind my mouth All of Me de God
that I may simply be an instrument that
proclaims Your Glory by proclaiming the
word of Truth suppress my carnal nature
that my only concern will be to lift you
up before your people wherever your
people gather to listen to this program
bless them in whatever country they may
be father bless the leaders of those
countries as I always say particularly
the host country of India May their
decisions allow the gospel to go forward
they god father place a special blessing
on all the little boys and little girls
protect them from harm and danger
protect them from sickness and diseases
they God and let them grow up to love
Jesus and to love his church bless the
visitors there father those who are not
s the Adventist touch them very very
personally God and blessed them
abundantly and for those who are sick
with covid-19 and any other ailment
touch them with your hand of mercy God
and deliver them from their afflictions
I pray in Jesus name
amen
relationships have
rules in John 14 reading from verse one
and we know it very well let not your
heart be troubled ye believe in God
believe also in me in my father's house
are many mansions if it were not so I
would have told you I go to prepare a
place for you observe the words of
Christ I go to prepare a place for you
and if I go and prepare a place for you
I will come again and receive you unto
myself that where I am there ye may be
also it's I and you are I and you I and
you in John
141:3 now Jesus says he he's preparing a
place and then he'll come back and take
us to him so that we can be where he is
but I asked the question isn't he with
us now the answer excuse me is yes but
he is not with us the way he absolutely
desires to be he is with us through the
spirit yes Jesus when he rose from the
grave and went back up to heaven he took
his Humanity with him a glorified body
Philippians 3 CH verse 20 and 21 Christ
took a glorious body when he came from
the grave the very same body we will
have but it is still physical because
Christ is still physical while he is
also God a great mystery he cannot be
with us and in us the way the Holy
Spirit can be and so he's he has
prepared a place and he's looking
forward to that day when we will be with
him physically where he is so that we
might be able to touch him and look
right into his eye and lean on his
shoulder and listen to his voice
personally that has not yet
come why does Jesus want that because
Christ believes in close and personal fa
tace relationships but relationships
have rules let us go to Genesis chapter
1 and see God's desire for relationships
Genesis 1 let's read from verse 26 or
just verse 26 and God said let us make
man in our image after our
likeness I want to create beings that
are just as I am in character in
thinking let us make man in our image
why so that God could have a
relationship with his creation
El writes in signs of the times April 22
1903 paragraph 5 we were brought into
existence because we were needed
remarkable statement signs of the tid
April 22 1903 paragraph 5 hello white
wres we were brought of course Adam and
Eve into existence because we were
needed God decided I needed someone to
love some beside the angels and the
unfallen world and so he made Humanity
why to love us that we might love him
along with that we read in Bible
commentary volume 1 page 1081 paragraph
2 God made the world to enlarge
Heaven two remarkable statements we read
in signs of the time April 22 1903
paragraph 5 we were brought into
existence because we were needed and
then we read in Bible comary volume 1
page 1081 paragraph 2 God made the world
to enlarge
heaven so that we by our lifestyle
should represent the lifestyle of Heaven
because God's original desire was that
the world would be an extension of
Heaven no wonder in the Lord's Prayer
Jesus said Our Father which are in
heaven Hallowed be thy name th thy
kingdom come thy will be done in earth
as it is in heaven why because God made
the world to enlarge heaven I'm saying
all of that to say God has always
desired a close relationship with his
creation intelligent creation and also
the animal creation and the the the
vegetable creation or you name it God
has always desired a relationship
particularly with those Made In His
Image but as I said
relationships have rules before I go any
further let me pray again father in
Heaven instruct me Teach Me direct me as
I try to represent you by presenting
truth in Jesus name I pray amen let us
go to John 15 as we continue
relationships have rules John 15 we
shall read from verse 12 of John
15 this is my
commandment that you love one another
notice it is not a suggestion it is not
a recommendation it is not advice it is
a command which means it makes no
difference how you feel about that
neighbor who steals your your your
produce from your garden it makes no
difference how you feel about your
political leader the Bible says excuse
me this is my
command biblical love is not based
necessarily on feeling it is based on a
response to God's command and we love
God by obeying his command this is my
command that you love one
another greater love hath no man than
this that a man lay down his life for
his friends now listen to Jesus ye are
my
friends if you do whatsoever I command
you if I were to ask in person if I were
present where you are in h orad and I
were to ask the congregation how many of
you are friends of Jesus I imagine all
hands would go up some would put up two
hands listen to Christ as he defines
what a friend of God is or how a friend
of God lives or
behaves ye are my friends if you do
whatsoever I command
you relationships have rules the
fundamental rule of a relationship a
friendship with God is obedience to God
you and I may say whatever we like if
we're not obeying God as he has revealed
his will to us we may be members of the
church we may be officers of the Union
the conference the division the GC we
are not a friend of God if our lives are
expressions of deliberate Disobedience
to God Jesus Christ who cannot lie he
said ye are my friends
if
condition if you do whatsoever I command
you henceforth I call you not servants
for the servant knoweth not what his
Lord doeth but I have called you friends
for all things that I have heard of my
father I have made note unto you a
friend of God is someone who has access
to the inner secrets of God he said the
servant does not have that privilege but
you my friends and I call you friends
because I've let you know what God told
me you know a benefit of Being A Friend
Of God is God gives us Revelations he
does not give to anyone
else special information privileged
information why when you are a friend of
God but the condition for friendship
with God is
obedience excuse me ye are my friends if
you do whatsoever I command
you look at Verse 18 and verse 19 of
John
15 if the world hate you meaning you're
not a friend of the world you know it
hated me before it hated
you if ye were of the world the world
would love his own in other words if you
were friend of the world the world would
love you but because you're not of the
world but I have chosen you out of the
world therefore the world hath you in
other words because you're not a friend
of the world but you're a friend of God
you're my
friend there are two friendship
situations in this
world friend of God or friend of the
world let us go to James chapter 4 we
read verse 4 James 4 verse4
ye adulterers and adulteresses know ye
not that friendship with the world is
enmity with God whosoever therefore will
be a friend of the world is the enemy of
God let me say that again well let James
say it again let the Bible say it again
ye
adulterers and
adulteresses know ye not that friendship
with the world
is enmity with
God which means you and I are either
friends of God or we're friends of the
world we cannot be friendly with
both Jesus said he that is not with me
is against me we're told from scripture
where either sheep or goats a person
who's a friend of God cannot be a friend
of the world or vice versa person he or
she who is a friend of the world cannot
be a friend of God but let us make an
application observe what Jesus said
about the basis of Friendship with him
or friendship with God here my friends
if ye do whatsoever I command you that
also applies to the world to be a friend
of the world we must do what the world
says in the way we dress we do what the
world says in the way we eat we do what
the world says in the way we we spend
our money we do what the world says in
the way we raise our children we do what
the world says in the way we engage in
Recreation we do what the world says in
the way we pursue romantic relationship
we do what the world says consequently
we are friends of the world because to
be a friend of the world you obey the
world to be a friend of God you obey
God
simple ye my friends if ye do whatsoever
I command you
and to be a friend of Jesus is to be an
enemy of the world and so I give you
James 4:4 again know ye not that
friendship with the world is enmity with
God in other words obeying the rules of
the world or differently said living by
the principles of the world this is
active obedience that makes that person
an enemy of God now the Bible say
doesn't say that God God is an enemy of
that person that person is an enemy of
God God doesn't hate
people question for you which I asked
earlier are you a friend of God do you
understand the rules of the relationship
and the rules of the relationship may be
condensed into one word
obey I am not promoting legalism
legalism is the attempt of a sinner to
save himself or herself by doing ab and
C you cannot work your way into heaven
now you can work your way into hell you
cannot work your way into heaven
obedience is not
legalism let me explain them inmates in
prison biblically they don't obey they
comply because there's a punishment
hanging over their head they comply
they're not in love with the prison
system they're not in love with the
warden of the prison so they comply The
Obedience God recognizes must be an
expression of Love listen to these words
Christ object lessons page 97 paragraph
3 the man who attempts to keep the
Commandments of God from a sense of
obligation merely because he is required
to do so will never enter into the joy
of obedience he does not obey when the
requirements of God are considered a
burden because they cut across human
inclination we may know that the life is
not a Christian Life True obedience is
the outworking of a principle within it
Springs from the love of righteousness
the love of the law of God the essence
of all righteousness is loyalty to Our
Redeemer this will lead us to do right
because it is right because right doing
is pleasing to God The Obedience God
accepts is that born out of love for him
the person just loves to do what's right
Psalm 106:3 the Bible says blessed are
they that keep judgment and he that
doeth righteousness at all times because
that person loves to do it because right
doing pleases God when Jesus says ye my
friends if ye do whatsoever I command
you we combine that with the previous
chapter John
14:15 if you love me keep my
Commandments and in John 15 vers 14 if
you are my friends keep my Commandments
combine the two if you say you're my
friend who loves me keep my Commandments
and the half brother of Jesus who wrote
the book of James he was the half
brother of Christ he tells us a
relationship with the world simply means
there is no relationship with God no
saving relationship with God all people
have a relationship with God the devil
has a relationship with God but it is a
hostile relationship the outright
flagrant sinner has a relationship with
God it is a hostile relationship we you
and I we desire a
relationship based on love
relationships have rules let us go to
James chapter 2 we'll read from verse
21 let me pray again father as I
continue in my weak way to preach the
truth help me strengthen me I pray in
Jesus name amen James chapter 2 we read
from verse
21 was not Abraham Our Father justified
by works when he had offered Isaac his
upon the altar see thou how Faith
wrought with his works and by works was
Faith made perfect and the scripture was
fulfilled which sayith Abraham believed
God and it was imputed unto him for
righteousness and he was called the
friend of God so we have he believed God
and the Bible say he was called the
friend of God but we know that Jesus
tells us friendship with God requires
obedience so when we read in James 2:23
that Abraham was called a friend of God
and he believes God that belief is the
belief that is expressed in obedience
because James says in the same chapter
verse 26 for the body without the spirit
is dead so faith without works is
theread Abraham obeyed God that's how he
expressed his belief in consequence he
was called by God a friend of
God and so Abraham was a friend of God
hundreds and hundreds of years ago
before Jesus said in John 15:14 ye are
my friends if you do whatsoever I
command you and God himself was a
witness to The Obedience of Abraham
Abraham kept my charge my Commandments
my statutes and my laws Genesis 26:5
rule relationships have rules and what
is the
rule ye are my friends if you do
whatsoever I command
you the wisest man who ever lives
Solomon the son of David a relative or
ancestor of Jesus Christ listen to what
he tells us in Ecclesiastes 1213 and 14
or just 13 let us hear the conclusion
of the whole matter fear God and keep
his Commandments for this is the whole
duty of
man fear God recognize who he is keep
his Commandments Express differently
obey him Express differently do whatever
he says Jesus said Year my friends if
you do whatsoever I command you Solomon
says your duty in love
life set out by God is to do whatever
God says in other words your duty my
duty as defined by God is to have a
friendly relationship with God and a
friendly relationship with God is based
squarely on
obedience out of
love let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter meaning
there are no exceptions excuse me this
is the whole
matter fear God keep his Commandments
this is the whole duty of man the whole
duty of man mankind is to have a
friendly relationship with God and that
friendship is preserved as we live a
life of loving obedience to God faith
and works page 100 paragraph 1 Christ
Christ or God desires or demands or
requires the entire surrender of the
heart before justification can take
place and in order for man to retain
justification there must be continual
obedience through active Living Faith
that works by
love he requires the entire surrender
that's an act of obedience let me
explain what I just mean
salvation has a
condition that condition is
obedience but you may say but how can I
obey before I'm saved follow me closely
salvation has a
condition no one is saved
unconditionally everyone is loved
unconditionally no one is saved
unconditionally let us recite the most
popular bible verse and say it
microscopically for God so loved the
world he loved us before we were born he
did not need our permission to love us
he just loved us remember Christ is the
lamb slain from the foundation of the
world before the foundation of the world
you see therefore God Loved Before he
actually created us so he did not need
our permission to love us God 's love is
not based on our mission now for God so
loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son the gift of Christ was not
based on human
permission because love must be
expressed he loved he gave now whosoever
believeth
Ah that's my part that's yours whosoever
believeth that's the
condition whosoever believeth should not
perish but have everlasting life
everlasting life is given to those who
obey God's request that we believe him
it is God who tells us to
believe when we believe we have
obeyed salvation is based on obedience
it's the condition sanctification its
condition is obedience then
glorification its condition is obedience
look at the sanctuary service we have
the outer Court the holy place the most
holy place in the outer Court we have
the altar of sacrifice that's Calvary we
put our faith in God that's Faith that's
belief we believe that's a condition we
come to the holy place the Candlestick
table of shoe bread the altar of incense
the the bread represents the word of God
the Candlestick the light which is the
word of God the spirit of God the
incense the merits of Christ sacrificed
we eat God's word because he has told us
to study his word to live by his word by
every word and so we
obey we that's just that's
sanctification justification the other
cour sanctification the holy place now
we come to the most holy place what do
we find the Ten
Commandments justification obedience
sanctification obedience glorification
obedience obedience is the condition
from beginning to end of salvation
of redemption for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life my
brothers and sisters no enemies of God
will enter God's kingdom we enter God's
kingdom as his friends you yourselves
would be very unwilling to allow an
enemy into your home you're not sure
what that person may do particularly if
you have little children you let the
enemy stay outside and you speak through
the doorway of through the window no
enemy of God will be admitted into his
kingdom because the Bible says
Revelation 22:14 blessed are they that
do his Commandments that they may have
right to the tree of life and may enter
in through the gates into the city now
if blessed are they that do his
Commandments blessed are they who are
his friends because his friends do
whatever he said only friends of God
will be admitted into that Kingdom but
God sent Jesus to try to call us in to a
friendship with him the holy spirit is
constantly trying to nudge us into go to
God he is your friend you are his enemy
but he's your friend now let's have
friendship on both side with God and
with you and the spirit tries to bring
us through Christ into a friendship with
the father and friendship with the
father is friendship with the son it's
friendship with the Holy Spirit it is
friendship with all the
Angels a friend of Heaven is someone who
obeys God and so I say the words of
Christ
again this is my
commandment that you love one another
and let me say quickly this friendship
will be severely
tested you know we have some friends who
are friends as long as everything is
fine when you get into trouble those
friends disappear we call those fair
weather Friends when the rain comes and
the snow comes as it's right now outside
my my house those friends disappear
Jesus is a friend that Stith closer than
a
brother which mean friendship with God
is stronger than a biological Bond now
you try to imagine that now you have
brothers and sisters you had no
choice you see family relationships
aren't choices they are imposed Upon Us
in the sense you know I have three
sisters I didn't choose them no I love
them yes I didn't choose them are you me
I didn't choose my mother I didn't
choose my father they're all connected
to me
biologically but I choose my friends let
me tell you again there's a friend that
Stith closer than a brother the Bible
says a a a friendship with God is
stronger than a bond between a mother
and a
child because friendships based on
choice not biology Choice we've got to
choose choose God we've got to choose
righteousness we've got to choose and
when that choice is made it establishes
a connection that is stronger than
biology and so the Bible says blessed
are they that do his
Commandments that they may have right to
the tree of life and may enter into the
gates into the city everyone who enters
that glorious City will be a friend of
God and what is a friend of God someone
who lives a life of loving obedience to
God it does not feel forced it is based
on the fact that that person to some
degree understands the tremendous
demonstration of love that came from God
when he sent someone equal with himself
Jesus Christ to die on that cross to
rise and to intercede on our behalf for
God so loved the world that he gave his
only begotten son you and I must say for
I so love God that I gave myself in
Friendship to him and the condition of
that friendship is
obedience this is my commandment that
you love one another greater love hath
no man than this that a man laid down
his life for his friends ye are my
friend if you do whatso have I command
you and I said earlier this friendship
will be tested very soon because in the
time of trouble we know that there will
be a law pass or just before the time of
trouble which will lead to the time of
trouble and the law will be the official
day of worship is Sunday and Adventist
we believe that when that law is passed
you and I will be confronted with an
official command of M Sunday's a Sabbath
opposed to the official command of God
the seventh day is the Sabbath now we'll
have to choose between friendship with
God obedience to God friendship with the
world obedience to the world and its
man-made
laws in order to stand strong when that
time comes and it's not far away I'm no
Prophet but you look at the times in
which we live it cannot be far away and
when it comes it will come suddenly
which means preparation has to be now
preparation to defend friendship with
God must OCC now and so right now you
decide I will not take exams on Sabbath
right now I will not work on Sabbath
right now I will not associate with
those whose lifestyles are worldly nor
extended Association unless it is for
their salvation right now I will live my
life by the principles of thus said the
Lord right now I will support the work
of the Gospel you make those decision
right now because each one of those
decisions is an expression of Friendship
with God so when that test comes
Sunday or Sabbath the world or God we
ought to be God rather than man when
that test comes you will choose God's
side because you've been practicing
faithfulness to God and obedience to God
you've been practicing and expressing
your friendship with God which is based
on do what I say not because you feel
forced but because you love the one who
issues the command Jesus Christ a test
is coming the test of friendship and the
test of friendship is based on the law
when Daniel was uh put in the Lion's Den
the reason for that was he did not pray
to Darius read it in Daniel chapter 6
and the princes and the presidents they
tried to find some reason to get Daniel
in trouble they couldn't they said we'll
find nothing against Daniel except we
find it against his law so they tried to
get him on the law and the world will
try to get us on the law and the law
simply represents the rules of our
relation ship with
God my listening
friend when we were
enemies Christ died for us because he
was not our enemy God has never been the
enemy of a sinner God is the sinner's
only true
friend now he invites you to have a
friendship relationship with him and
that relationship is based squarely on
thus say the Lord plain and simple
obedience now I ask you again how many
of you are friends of God I presume all
of you will raise a head let me ask this
how many of us are obeying God what you
say is fine it is what you do that
really matters with God that's why we're
saved by faith we are judged by
works we are judged by work in other
words God is saying well you said you
love me that's what you said that's your
profession of faith let me see how you
lift and the law judges that you will
say I'm a friend of God and I will ask
you do you obey God if the answer is
sometimes that's a friendship that's in
danger serious danger we need a
friendship that the devil cannot
separate we need a friendship that the
devil cannot damage in other words we
need a friendship that is so strong we
prefer to die than to than to uh be
unfaithful to that friendship and Jesus
said great have no man than this or
there's no greater friendship that a man
lays down his life for his
friends because Christ was the Friend Of
The Sinner he laid down his life for his
friends because Christ loved his father
so much he died at the request of the
father for Sinners and so Jesus can said
therefore do my father love me because I
lay down my life that I may take it John
10:17 actually Ela says the love the
father has for Christ the love the
Angels had for him the love the unfallen
worlds had for him somehow got deeper
when he actually gave up his life for
Sinners and I can find that quotation
give it to Pastor Jad he can give it to
the churches never was the son of God
more loved by the Father the Angels the
unfallen worlds than when he laid down
his life now I can't understand that how
can God love more I don't know but
that's what the Bible says that's what
El tells us and so I'm saying to you my
friend you must value friendship with
God more than your very life because
Christ put your life ahead of his he put
your life ahead of his he risked
everything why because he is your friend
now he tells you I made that risk I pay
that price demonstrate your friendship
to me by simply obeying me and it's
reason able to us can I obey someone who
dies for me the answer is yes someone
who has died for me does not mean me any
harm at all anything he tells me I can
do he has proved his reliability by
giving his life for me I can trust that
person if you're my
friend keep my Commandments and those
Commandments include remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy and I'm
talking to my my friends do not s the
Adventist six days shalt thou labor and
do all thy work but the seventh day is
the Sabbath of the Lord thy God in it
Thou shalt not do any work thou nor thy
son nor thy daughter thy manservant nor
thy maid servant nor thy cattle nor thy
stranger that is within thy gates for in
six days the Lord made Heaven and Earth
the sea and all that in them is and
rested the seventh day wherefore the
Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hallowed
those of you listening who not s
adamist ask God to give you the courage
to obey him and that includes the
Sabbath commandment the fourth
Commandment Sunday is not the Sabbath of
the Bible it never was it isn't now it
shall never be the seventh day Sabbath
it was it is and it shall always be from
one new moon to another and from one
Sabbath to another shall all come to
worship before me and so as your distant
friend from thousands of miles I'm
asking you now in the presence of a holy
God contact the hyroad SDA Church
contact some SDA church close to you and
tell the leaders I want to know more
about the Seventh Day Adventist
teachings and you'll discover that the
Seventh Day Adventist teaching are the
teachings found in this book contact
that church ask for Bible studies which
will lead to baptism it will put a smile
on the face of God
take the step towards becoming a friend
of God obey God keep his seventh day
Sabbath little children you're not yet
baptized think about it and when the
spirit moves you tell your mother tell
your father I want to be baptized and
they will prepare you and with the
pastor they'll set the day do not hold
back or blot out that conviction anyone
listening to me deepen your friendship
with God make a decision to be baptized
if you have not yet been if you have
dream lifted from Christ decide to be
rebap tized evangelism page 375 when a
soul is truly reconverted let that Soul
be rebaptised let him renew his Covenant
with God and God will renew his Covenant
with him you've drifted from God you've
lived the life of the world you've been
in church physically but spiritually
you've been a friend of the world make a
decision to be rebap tized inform the
leaders make that choice reestablish
that friendship with God I say again ye
my friends if you do whatsoever I
command you and all he refers to is the
decalog of the Ten Commandments which
includes commandment four remember the
Sabbath day God yearns to have a
friendship with you return that yearning
by developing a friendship with him by
yielding your life to him and allowing
him to work in you you make the decision
and he will provide the power to
preserve and strengthen that
relationship
relationships have rules and Jesus says
the rule is to be a friend of mine you
must obey me and I say again it is easy
to be a friend of someone who gave his
life for you let's
pray Father in heaven we thank you for
your word we thank you God for the
Simplicity of the essentials of the
Gospel in the name of Jesus Christ their
God if I have said anything I should not
have said forgive me now dear God I ask
you to send your spirit or direct your
spirit to Target that person who is in
the valley of
decision that person who needs to make a
decision to be baptized to take that
step towards a meaningful friendship
with God touch that person who needs to
resume that relationship because he or
she has drifted from God and damaged the
relationship and to come back through
rebaptism speak to that friend de God
that visitor who's not an Adventist tell
that person that your Sabbath has always
been and still is the seventh day of the
week and move upon that person to make a
decision to be baptized dear God bless
all those who listen I mean every single
person individually bless each person as
if that person alone is on the face of
the Earth but in a very special way
bless the host Church in an extra
special way bless all the little
children I pray heal the sick remove
covid-19 ease pain and suffering dear
God Keep Us Faithful even unto death
bless India the host country father
bless the leaders bless them guide them
in their decisions and their
deliberations and father bless all
countries represented by those listening
thank you for loving us even when we
were your enemies and thank you for
providing a path to Friendship and that
path is simple obedience from the heart
thank you Father we love you we long to
see you keep Us Faithful until that
great day when we shall see his face we
pray in Jesus name amen